it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you enter the long awaited
steampunk victorian world with
blood-borne similar to its dark soul
roots you don all sorts of ridiculous
weaponry against piles of vicious
monsters waiting to one-shot you back to
your grave quicker movement allows for
more dodges ducks and rolls in your
fights but if you are to fail you simply
touch your blood stain to retrieve your
souls I mean your blood echoes to keep
on truckin however if a creepy villager
happens to be near your blood stain he
absorbs those blood echoes and then you
have to kill him to get back where you
started good luck become the beast on
the 24th oh but we're not done yet
putting you in harm's way because
Slenderman is arriving on current-gen
consoles this week to make you punch
your monitor in pure horror slender the
arrival was originally released on last
gen and PC and starts with you in the
wilderness alone with nothing but a
haunting feeling shortly you'll find a
flashlight which is the closest thing
you're going to find a weapon for a low
price of ten dollars you'll get the
scariest game currently available on the
ps4 and Xbox one so beware of the
faceless man on the 24th dive into the
DC Universe this week as your favorite
characters to battle it out in a
familiar free-to-play MOBA experience
Batman Superman Joker Wonder Woman
poison ivy they're all they're all your
favorites are fighting and destructive
locations like Gotham in standard MOBA
fashion you follow drones and try to get
the last hit for credits where you'll
spend those in stores for items that
will help you turn the battle if there's
a reason to allow another mobile in this
world it's got to be the DC characters
so play is doomsday on the 26th you've
probably seen it at events in the last
few years boasting its similarity to the
classic RPG baldur's gate but pillars of
eternity is finally making its debut on
PC this week the custom rule system is
heavily inspired by classic and
contemporary tabletop fantasy
role-playing games you'll get six
attributes kors standard races and
classes a role to hit combat system and
strength based personal character
inventories conveniently calculated with
a virtual 100 sided die
start your dungeon dive on the 26 this
week Xbox gets a freebie with forza
horizon 2 presents fast and furious it
will not require Forza horizon 2 the
most recent entry in the forts of
franchise turn 10 is closely modeling
the in-game cars up to the vehicles in
the movies such as the 1970 plymouth
barracuda and the 2015 dodge charger
after april 10th Forza horizon 2
presents fast and furious is going to
cost you ten dollars so if you want to
pick it up do it soon not to be outdone
handsome Jack puts his beautiful mug
back in your face with the handsome Jack
collection coming to current gen
playstation and xbox both Borderlands 2
and Borderlands the pre-sequel with all
DLC including all the new level caps and
fancy wardrobes are yours and the full
claptrap in a box edition comes with a
phone controlled claptrap confirming my
beliefs once again that money does in
fact buy happiness you can pick up that
package on the 24 for further details
visit gamespot com release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week